[Music]
one of the more passionate baseball
voices chris mad dog russo host of mad
dog unleashed on sirius xm radio channel
82 and he hosts high heat on the mlb
network mad dog joins us on the program
doggie good to talk to you i want to go
back to the preseason i'm listening to
you afternoons doing your radio show and
we were looking at the over under for
the san francisco giants
right and i thought it was 73 74 and a
half how did we get from that to 107 for
this team
great danny i love you great to be on
you know how much i love you on this
show yeah of no way would you have
thought san francisco would be at this
level they've had a lot of players who
have made a contribution two stats that
are interesting about the giants one you
know they've got 17 players who have hit
five or more home runs
17 guys have that's a contribution and
number two you know they've got 18 pinch
hit home runs which is an all-time
record so 18 times this year
kepler put a guy in a pinch hit and 18
times this year the guy hit the ball out
of the ballpark i mean so they have had
a lot of resourcefulness they got
everybody's made a contribution they've
had a big year out of the shortstop
crawford they've had a big year out of
the catcher and they've had a lot of
these pitchers alex wood dausman logan
webb will never nobody ever heard of
they've had a lot of these guys go out
there and have very good years on the
mount and as a result they set the
all-time giant record with wins in a
regular season with 107. and here's the
key now in what i think dan and i know
charlie will say the same thing when you
have monolith later who i think is going
to be the series of the agents
can the giants
season success with a bunch of guys that
you and i couldn't pick out of the
lineup before the year began will those
guys
translate now into a short series
because usually in a short series you
know you take the team with the better
started pitching and the better star
which the dodgers have and now the
giant's got a bunch of guys the wilmer
flores is solano's duggar guys you've
never heard of are they going to play as
well as they did in a short series as
they did in 162. and that is the key in
this series if you think they will you
gotta like them if you think they won't
take the dodgers
would you have rather face the dodgers
of the cardinals if you're the giants
well i i think that you're gonna have to
probably go through the dodgers
eventually
and the old argument is it's ian you
covered the nba forever it's easier to
beat jordan three times than to beat
jordan four times so i would say the
same thing here if you had to play the
giant at dodgers if you're the giants
and you're a fan beat them three times
to the four times now i think it's a
mistake with baseball and they should
change it i think it's a negative for
the giants because with the best record
they should not be playing a team with
the second best record in the second
round of playoffs in a divisional series
the dodge giant should be playing a
braves right now and the giants should
be playing milwaukee but because the
dodgers of the wild card team they look
at the wild card status more
significantly than they look at the win
total and as a result the dodgers are
automatically the fourth seed which i
think is unfair to the giants i think
they should change that we'll see if
they do down the road but in the big
picture if you had to go through l.a
danny you'd probably rather have to beat
him three times instead of four times
and this is what we always look at the
end result and then we react and because
it's a big market team in the dodgers
and they had the one game wild card
maybe baseball changes this if i said it
hey at the beginning of the year hey you
guys got a problem with the one game
playoff
nobody has a nobody probably would have
a problem
and i mentioned this if tampa and
toronto had a one game playoff do you
think there's a national outcry
the answer is no it's just because
the dodgers and the yankees oh my god
they had to do a one game playoff
well listen the dodgers are also 106
games you know the highest toll in the
history of the sport for a second place
team and they are the defending champs
and that's why danny in my eyes you got
to give the dodgers an incredible amount
of credit they could not lose that game
last night yeah they had an incredible
amount of pressure on them you know it's
1-1 in a late innings
that is a game that they had to win
defending champ it would have been a
disaster would ruin their season so the
fact that they won that game showed you
we knew they had gumption anyway but it
reinforced the fact that they got a lot
of toughness and i guarantee you this
on sixth avenue
acai relief
you think baseball one of the cardinals
in the divisional round against the
giants
not a chance because all as you said all
we would have done is scream how unfair
it would have been for the dodgers to
win 106 games and in two and a half
hours their season's open as it turns
out it was four and a half hours which
is another story together but i mean the
fact is you got the right match up and
the dodgers i think you'd agree showed a
lot of gumption yeah this is a very hard
series to call i mean
almost impossible who wins this series
with the giant i think it's going to go
on five games ninth inning 2-2 next
thursday night in san francisco take
your pick
if you're a yankee fan
how's your morale
i think if you're a yankee fan you're
very down on boone you're very down on
the gm
you have down on the fact that since
2009 you haven't been to a world series
you hate the fact you lost the red sox
you also hate the fact that tampa has
now owned the yankees they won the
division they beat you last year uh so
this is a bad time now if you're a
yankee fan you're sick of you're sick of
joey gallo that's the last time you ever
want to see him there's no way you want
gary sanchez on your team next year
those are two out from that standpoint
uh you're very annoyed at cole he gave
him 325 million dollars to win this kind
of game that he was supposed to win two
nights ago when he laid an egg couldn't
get more than six outs so if you're a
yankee fan right now you are you had to
go to the wall last weekend against
tampa the wall
the ninth inning of game three before
you got one on an infield single are
crying out loud so if you're a yankee
fan right now you want heads to roll
kohl's head can't roll yeah uh you know
i don't know what they're gonna do with
cashman i think they're probably being
booned back gallo they have a contract
for next year he's got us awful i mean
you would be
i can't believe i said it at the time
when i made that trade and obviously
we've seen enough of gary sanchez to
life for last lifetime so sanchez
gallows have to go we'll see what they
do with cashman with al what he does
with him and then cashman will decide
what to do with boom it's not boone's
fault but he's living there for four
years and haven't gotten real world
series would you rather be a mets fan or
a yankee fan
wow
uh i guess because cohen's got more
money than you can you know he's got a
ton of money and i think he'll go over
the luxury tax plus i think now he'll
bring in billy bean
or maybe the kid from milwaukee if the
brewers allow them to talk to david
stearns as a gm i guess and it's and
that's a good question
it's not great out of the way i guess i
say the mets i guess
do you think baseball is looking at
astros dodgers
like we this is what we need like oh
absolutely danny like i don't know if
there's another match up that
no
absolutely do you think they want you
think they want you they want braves and
the white sox and the world series
didn't every minute see the nfl
can get away with any world super bowl
if they gave you jaguars and cardinals
who you know we wouldn't care
the nba needs that star wins anyway so
you're okay with the nba you get the
lakers and you got giannis i mean you're
baseball
they need the market size and dodgers in
houston
you'll be into it i'll be into it
they don't they won't like the scandal
nonsense but that series with all those
hall of famers will have great juice
i don't know if they're going to get it
but that series would be great and
that's the one you could use no question
about it i i i don't want to paraphrase
you i want to make sure i'm accurate but
it felt like you're not as all in on the
astros cheating scandal yes as most
right
that's 100
here's what bothers me
about the people saying the astros
championship was tarnished
we know cheating is deplorable give more
the grief
in that series against the yankees in
which yankee fans go crazy did you know
the yankees hit 158 in that series and
they hit 160 with men in scoring
position the yankees could couldn't hit
themselves out of a paper bag in that
game seven or that seven gamer against
the astros that's number one number two
the dodgers
blew leads and a save in game two
and lost game seven
when you lose two games at home
in the world series which they did one
of which they blew a save in the ninth
inning i mean really you went two and
two at home
the astros were not cheating on the road
two and two at home in the world series
that takes a little steam
in my eyes as a fan that takes a little
steam of saying you know the astros
cheated their way to a championship well
in and out the dodgers won the first
game they blew a game save game two
saved and then they had game seven with
kershaw and darvish and and they lost
five one
can we take it easy and the yankees and
i know cashman says this to all the time
well they make a big deal the astros
took our championship brian your team
hit 150 in a seven game [ __ ] at least
acknowledge the fact that you couldn't
hit at least give me that before you sit
there and tell me the answers but your
big question is fun dan ask those
dodgers in two weeks whether the
commissioner gets into that
the fans will
and you and i both know that will you
have a rod on your show any time soon
yeah you know
i can't get around in any way let me can
i ask somebody a question yeah
it's the top of the ninth inning i know
it's 6-2 red sox
all right 38 000 at fenway they beat the
hated yankees and a-rod is breaking down
garrett cole's 2022
you got to be serious now i mean that's
not where we want to go with this and
then the night and then he said he'd be
better in his sophomore year a-rod he's
been on the yankees for a couple of
years oh my god that was listen i know
that is part of your family and you know
and i mean you got a lot listen you're a
hall of famer based on that in a lot of
ways
that was not that was not a big time
broadcast we got to be fair we got to be
fair
you're a broadcaster well you know what
you have to do dog is you have to put a
third person in with a rod
to protect him
and and i think if he's your main guy
um
i i don't that's not what he does well
he tries too hard
yes well he's trying to be an analyst
instead of just being an analyst i i
just had mike lowell on i don't know if
you saw what he and cliff floyd did last
night on uh the mlb network no mlb
network they broke down bogart's throw
to home plate to get air oh i didn't see
that it was excellent
it was spectacular
but it was inside baseball
and it was just wonderful tv and when
you're in that role you gotta give me
something i mean tim mccarver is the one
who started this him and tony kubak like
they were really good at getting you
inside you know between the lines and
not talking this peripheral stuff where
you're going
what notice what's in front of you and i
when a rod starts talking about garrett
cole next season i went
what did i miss
because i i just popped in on him
talking about i go
did something did i did i miss something
and i realized i didn't and i just
thought oh my god somebody's got to tell
him you know a rod in the middle of the
game is telling us about the yankees
can't beat tampa and they gotta spend
like a mouth come on a rod i don't want
to get into major market mid market this
is the playoffs the yankees in a red sox
oh
listen and it's not braz and rizz
version's in a tricky spot and i love
maddie i hate to even say it he didn't
have a great night either let's be
honest schwerber did not go to the red
sox from the from the cups he went there
from the nationals
i mean come on uh anyway who am i look
you're no you're a baseball's lifeguard
you know yeah that's it in a lot of ways
all right who do you who do you like in
giants dodgers let me hear your take go
ahead
i don't like the giants strike me as
like the west coast version of tampa
you're disappointed you're not sure who
they are but they play baseball the
right way
i i'm gonna go with the experience with
the dodgers because i you know you get
in these moments where you get tight
like bellinger's done nothing all year
long and what did he do last night got
on base three times and still you know
he he was there he
earned that walk in the in the ninth
like those little things
and then you know you have the
game-winning home run from somebody who
has been the nl uh csmb
and he was
and he was eight for 70 in the and by
the way can somebody explain to me how
mike schiltz
starts the ninth inning with tj
mcfarland who was released by a team in
june because he's worried about he's
worried about gavin lux what
i mean my goodness uh keep gallegos in
the game i mean what are you doing oh my
god i went and then mcfarland what does
he do and then he takes him out when you
want him to make sure that bellinger
can't steal second base have the lefty
now
that was let's be that way he was not
that was not a john mcgraw moment
or a whitey herzog moment in the ninth
inning by show you got to be fair you
got to be sure ah
good to talk to you dawg andy i love you
baby
all right buddy that's chris mad dog
russo he's got high heat
on mlb network